spending a couple of segments talking
about kids and money with my daughter
Rachael Cruz and there's the co-author
of the book number one New York Times
best-selling book with me the book is
called smart money smart kids it's kind
of teach your kids how to handle money
so when they grow up they don't live in
your basement and so we went back to the
very youngest of the young of children
because rachel has announced that she's
got our second grandchild on the way
Papa Dave is happy and so little girl so
Princess Cruise is on the way we have
Prince William over on the other side of
Princess Cruise I heard this yesterday
sir William is the u.s. princess and he
is a little prince so he's awesome he's
14 months old Rachel's sister Denise's
child so we're talking about you know
what it takes to what the way people
overreact really to babies is what it
amounts to and it's not anything to do
with the actual baby's needs that cause
you to go broke it's all the cute stuff
that's out there and it is cute I mean I
want to go by University of Tennessee
football stuff and that's cute so yeah
register crew little princess cruise
needs a cheerleader outfit right so
Williams won around with his little
toddler belly sticking out at the
football game the other day with this
little orange thing Loren shirt on and
the whole place is just stopped watching
him you know they're cute it's it's easy
to spend money on that stuff there's
nothing wrong with spending the money on
it the thing is is if you're in the
middle of your debt snowball while you
have little children like that you know
you got to have the household on a
budget you're cleaning up your mess so
that you can living like no one else so
later you can do something more
important than buying them a onesie that
they wear once like that's where the
name comes from if they wear low wear
onesies once and that's why they make
them that's why they call them that and
because they grow so fast you get 26
outfits at showers or whatever and
they're never there's no way they can't
possibly wear them all before they
outgrow them and that's called logic
yeah but then there's a motion yeah
they're like me the mothers that you're
like but I want the 26 cute onesies you
know I mean so yeah you learn
self-control you do they're cute but you
don't ask you have to just kind of think
through it yes you know in proportion to
your budget
use your freakin brain now if you've got
the money you want to buy some cute
stuff that's fine and you got because
you know you got you know are we going
to furnish the nursery so that it
qualifies for pictures in Southern
Living or are we going to fund the kids
college fund because the nursery is not
going to last in about three years
you're going to repaint it and we're
going to take down the baby bed and
we're going to put in a real bed and so
on and so but that college fund now that
one lasts and that's a big deal and
these these little things can affect the
big things you guys are already looking
at some of that aren't you yes and I
think you see how expensive things are
so you start to learn to shop smart you
know things like consignment sales and
things like secondhand stores I mean
even though it's like a crib I'm like I
don't know I don't know if I need a
brand-new crib I would be okay you know
finding one that was used in a store you
know there's some great stores here in
Nashville with baby stuff so I think
it's just it's being wise and just
realizing like you said it's just it's
not it's not the the need of the child
for every single thing you know the wife
warmers or the great diaper bag you know
what wife warmers would wipe there's
like there's things out today dad calm
you have to warm my wife wipe warmers oh
my god cuz they're cold oh my god so uh
yeah yeah there's money you can say
right there you really are all that and
you probably don't use it cuz you end up
changing the kid in the living room half
the time you don't go stairs for the web
so I mean yes you start to be smart
about it but it's so easy to go
overboard and I think you know if you
spend too much time on Facebook and
blogs and all of that and you start to
look at what everyone has and it's like
no one idea there's a guilt trip that
goes with this cuz you're like a bad mom
if you don't have all this crap yes or
you don't feed organic I mean there's a
lot of stuff and I'm not even a mom yet
I mean the child still in the womb for
me and I still feel these I start to
feel these pressures already because
yeah there's this standard now and the
standard is thrown in your face
constantly with raising kids today with
the stuff aspect of it all and parents
never go overboard on stuff like
Halloween oh yeah that's coming up isn't
it this week yeah this week it's going
to be awesome
we have 426 team members and we have
trick-or-treating here in the building
and so they have 4:30
well this building will be covered in
kids covered I mean looks like an
anthill it is awesome and cute from now
on but it is always interesting to look
at the moms and the dads and the
costumes and how really creative fun and
effective some of those homemade
costumes are and they had a lot of fun
put them together and doing that stuff
and then the others just go struggle
check and for 60 bucks I mean it's it's
crazy how come I'm wearing something
once here we go yeah you're wearing that
one time now again if you make if you
make good money and you're out of debt
and you've got your emergency fund it's
okay to do some stuff like that it's fun
but that you know how expensive your
kids Halloween costume is says more
about you than it does about your kid
well Johnny wouldn't know you wanted to
shut up it was cute and you fell over
laughing or you fell over in a pile of
cuteness watching it and felt like you
had to have it
you think I was cute when y'all took an
old bedsheet cut two holes and put it
over you know a face we were ghosts
that was one Halloween costume was it
really a ghost with a sheet oh really oh
yeah oh yeah that was pretty lame oh
yeah so you're clearly I didn't roll
over and cuteness no and roll over
cuteness on Helen oh I don't know how
old your I don't remember that yeah we
were young the whole with the whole
bunch all three of you know just me just
you you want a middle child the middle
they abused middle child ends up
happening that's why we got scarred okay
uh and of course Christmas yes yeah we
can't go overboard for Christmas oh yeah
so the holidays are coming up I'm sure
we'll talk about that more in future
dates how to do that wise yeah and how
to work boundaries with the out of
control grandparents and that kind of
stuff too where you know you're being
fairly reasonable that mom and dad are
off the ranch and own stuff and so and
it is hard as a grandparent to stand
back and say well I could do this easily
and they don't want to do it and you
know Rachel's going to go by consignment
curry oven we could buy crib you know it
wouldn't be a big a deal where she could
- you're just cheap but um you're not
whence the Winston is I'm a smart now
he's the saver yes he is the saver so
but you know we just look
that kind of thing and so how to set
some boundaries in some of those areas
as well is a big deal so I'm often asked
at your stage where you're pregnant with
your first child hey I'm ready to start
the college fund can I start the college
fund no you can't open an educational
savings account for someone that does
not have a social security number and
you can't get a social security number
until they're born so you have to wait
you can have everything filled out and
apply for it you know get the Social
Security pretty quickly it's issued very
fast but so you won't miss but a few
weeks probably of investing but you
technically cannot open the account now
could you have your two thousand dollars
set aside for your educational savings
account for the first year ready to go
to fund after the baby comes yes yes you
can yes you can and so our question also
comes up how to handle monetary gifts
from family I guess for the child have
you run into that question much like the
not personally but I'm saying when
you're out on the road speaking and
things people are asking you questions
or you know my mother wants to give my
child ten thousand dollars or five
thousand dollars or whatever or they
want to fund their kids caught grandkids
college fund or something like that have
you run into that much no not a lot but
it's I mean a few times I have and it's
usually seen the way the parent tells me
about it's usually in a good spirit
saying hey they want to they want to
give this as a gift do you think that's
a good idea and so I always go back to
the idea you know as long as no strings
are attached and it is a gift that
they're giving them you know and you
guys have a good relationship then most
the time if it's you know reasonable it
usually doesn't spoil the relationship
between the parent and the grandparent
for the most part but yeah really it's
kind of Henry clouds book boundaries is
um or is the grandparents trying to gain
access to something they shouldn't have
access to a level of control or
something with this gift I'll give them
ten thousand dollars but he has to go to
school I want him to go to write this
silly like that or um you know or I have
seen grandparents who are out of control
and they want to go borrow the money
to do something for the grandkid and we
don't recommend that either that
violates everything we talked about so
well we've got another baby on the way
congratulations Rachel thank you very
much
papa Dave there we go you're welcome I
love it it's fun stuff can't wait to
have a little girl Winston said the
other night and I agree with him it's
weird we've got the little boy and the
little girl you instantly once you just
hear that you feel protective the level
of need to protect goes way up for some
reason
that's very cool all right thanks Ron
check out the book smart money smart
kids it's available at Dave Ramsey comm
if you want to learn how to raise money
smart kids from Rachael Cruz and Dave
Ramsey good to have you Rach
you
you